ya vimos que nh 4 más viene h 3 son un
par conjugado ha sido base echemos un
vistazo al nh 4 más el ión amonio
funciona como un ácido y dona un protón
al agua para formar h 3 o más y como nh
4 más dona un protón nos queda
nh 3 y el k para esta reacción es de 5.6
por 10 a la menos 10 ahora echemos un
vistazo al nh 3 sabemos que es una base
débil y tomará un protón del agua
formando nh 4 más y como le quitamos un
protón al agua nos queda h menos y como
hablamos de una base el café para esta
reacción es 1.8 por 10 a la menos 5
qué pasa si juntamos estas reacciones
bueno tenemos
dos moléculas de agua como reactivos
vamos a escribir h2o + h2o y qué me
dicen del amonio
tenemos un amonio en los reactivos pero
también tenemos uno en los productos así
que se cancelan y lo mismo ocurre con el
amoniaco tenemos un nh3 en los reactivos
y un nh3 en los productos se cancela así
que de reactivos sólo nos quedan dos
moléculas de h2o y de productos tenemos
h 3 o más y o h menos entonces tenemos
el guión y tronío
y el guión hidróxido esta es la reacción
de auto ionización del agua en donde una
molécula de agua funciona como un ácido
y la otra funciona como una base
produciendo h 3 o más
h - ahora la constante de equilibrio
para la autorización del agua es k w que
es igual a 1.0 por 10 a la menos 14
entonces al juntar estas dos reacciones
obtenemos esta reacción pero qué ocurre
con el caa y café para que podamos
obtener k w
bueno acá por café para un par conjugado
ha sido base es igual a k w
entonces acá es igual a 5.6 por 10 a la
menos 10 y cate es igual a 1.8 por 10 a
la menos 5 usemos la calculadora tenemos
5.6 por pieza a la menos 10
1.8 por 10 a la menos 5 esto es igual a
1.0 por 10 a la menos 14 así que esto es
igual a 1.0 por 10 a la menos 14 que
corresponde al valor de cada w entonces
cuando juntamos reacciones para obtener
una reacción general simplemente
multiplicamos las constantes de
equilibrio para obtener la constante de
equilibrio de la reacción general que en
este caso es k w
ahora el k es igual a la concentración
de los productos sobre la concentración
de los reactivos
es decir la concentración de h 3 o más
la concentración de amoniaco y todo esto
dividido entre la concentración de
amonio entre la concentración de amonio
entonces todo esto representa acá y
ahora vamos con el cap de aquí tenemos
el cate que también corresponde a la
concentración de los productos es decir
nh4 más x o h menos
entre la concentración de nh 3 que nos
queda bueno la concentración de amonio
se cancela al igual que la concentración
de amoniaco y nos queda la concentración
de h 3 o más por la concentración de h -
y esto es igual a 1.0 por 10 a la menos
14 así que esta relación entre k
cate y cat w es muy importante porque si
conocemos uno podemos calcular al otro
por ejemplo si tenemos un ácido fuerte
como él
hcl su base conjugada sl - el a nyon
cloruro como hcl es un ácido muy fuerte
eso significa que tiene un valor
extremadamente alto de acá
y qué pasará con el café de la base
conjugada bueno como el k
es muy alto
entonces el café debe ser muy bajo para
que esto sea igual acá w así que
tendremos un valor muy pequeño de café y
esta es la forma de expresar
matemáticamente que entre más fuerte sea
un ácido más débil es la base conjugado
hcl es un ácido muy fuerte así que tiene
un valor muy muy alto de acá
y su base conjugado el año en cloruro
tiene un valor muy muy pequeño de café
lo que significa que es una base muy
débil ahora veamos un problema en donde
calcularemos unos de esos valores la
metilamina es una base débil y su café
es de 3.7 por 10 a la menos 4 el
problema nos pide que calculemos el
valor de k
para el ión metil amonio ch3 nh3 más
entonces tiene
un par conjugado ácido base y sólo hay
un protón de diferencia entre los dos
así que podemos usar nuestra ecuación
acá a por cape es igual a k w
vamos a sustituir el valor de café y nos
queda acá a por 3.7 por 10 a la menos 4
es igual acá w que es de 1.0 por 10 a la
menos 14 calculemos acá
tenemos 1 por 10 a la menos 14 entre 3.7
por 10 a la menos 4 es igual a 2.7 por
10 a la menos 11 entonces acá
es igual a 2.7 por 10 a la menos 11 éste
es nuestro valor de k
para el ión metil amonio ahora la
ecuación que tenemos es que a por cape
es igual a k w pero vamos a aplicar el
logaritmo en ambos lados de la igualdad
nos queda logaritmo tk
por cape es igual al logaritmo de k w y
el logaritmo de caá por café es lo mismo
que logaritmo de k
más logaritmo de café que es igual a
logaritmo de k w y si cambiamos todo al
signo contrario nos queda menos
logaritmo de k
más menos el logaritmo de café es igual
a menos el logaritmo de cada w observen
que el menos logaritmo de caá es igual
al pk
y el menos logaritmo de café es igual al
pk b así que tenemos pk a más de cabe es
igual a menos el logaritmo de k w que es
igual a 14 14.00 porque el menos
logaritmo de 1.0 por 10 a la menos 14 es
igual a 14.00 así que hemos encontrado
otra ecuación que podemos usar ahora
tomemos el valor de caja que acabamos de
calcular y encontremos el pk a el pk a
es igual a menos el logaritmo
27 por 10 a la menos 11 usemos la
calculadora menos logaritmo de 2.7 por
10 a la menos 11 es igual a 10.57
entonces el pk
es igual a 10.57 estas son nuestras dos
cifras significativas porque tenemos dos
cifras significativas aquí entonces este
es el pk
para el guión metil amonio pero
supongamos que ahora nos dan el pk ante
el metil amonio y nos piden que
calculemos el pkt de la metilamina cuál
es el pkt bueno sólo necesitamos
sustituir el pk
en esta ecuación entonces tenemos
10.57 más
tecate es igual a 14 el pkt es igual a
3.43 y para corroborar nuestro resultado
sabemos que el menos logaritmo de este
número nos debe de dar el mismo valor
entonces menos logaritmo de 3.7 por 10 a
la menos 4 es igual a 3.43 que es justo
lo que obtuvimos el pp es igual a 3.43
entonces esta es la relación entre k
icade y también hablamos de la relación
entre pk
y te cabe